you know something interesting to me
happen that this year I actually saw
enough for the movies that came out this
year to feel comfortable doing a top 10
list this is something I haven't started
doing since I've started making videos
it's something I used to do back when I
was blogging more but at that point I'm
I was also seeing movies more frequently
and closer when they actually came out
these days my free time if not a ton of
it so I tend to not get to movies right
away which you may have noticed from the
fact that I don't have a lot of reviews
up here but you know what it's the end
of the year I feel like I can do this
now I am still gonna say up front I have
not seen every movie that came out this
year didn't even come close there's
still a lot of things that came out this
year that I want to see but haven't
gotten to and I'm sure for people who
had a more exhaustive experience in
terms of the movies that came out this
year they're gonna see a lot of
emissions but this is based only around
what I saw so you know what this is
subjective as hell with that cleared up
and noted starting at number 10 300 rise
of an empire if I known at the time I
thought that I was going to be doing a
top 10 at the end of the year I never
would have called putting this on there
it does not deserve to be any higher
than this but it does serve some
recognition for a couple of reasons
first off it surprisingly manages to
justify its own existence I love 300 I
understand why a lot of people don't
there's a lot of very legitimate
criticisms about that movie but I liked
it a lot I think it's a lot of fun and I
think this film managed to both capture
what that film did without feeling like
a complete retread they get a lot of
mileage just out of the fact that a lot
of the action takes place on boats
instead of on land it's interesting the
way they kind of pick apart what
happened in the first movie and almost
kind of undercut it in a way but
absolutely the show still on this Abe
agreed her presence on her performance
alone really is what put this thing on
the list if the other performance had
been up to the caliber that she would
have been honestly this might have been
a top five number nine the lego movie
all together now everything is awesome
boom I just love the joy of this movie I
love that it is a movie about
inventiveness and about creativity and
about being a child visually it's
wonderful recreating that sort of
handmade LEGO brick film look and using
Lego for literally everything even water
effects it's Lego it's visually exactly
what it needed to be in store eyes it's
much deeper it's much funnier it's just
better than it had any right to be
number eight x-men days of future past
I'm really glad Brian and came back to
this franchise and I'm glad he brought
everybody along with him I love the
marrying of the original cast and the
cast from first class I feel like it was
a really good send up for the original
cast and now it kind of feels okay that
we're probably done with them it felt
wrong and it felt sore having the last
film of that group b x men the last
stand now you know what it feels good I
feel like I can move on now number seven
edge of tomorrow man this is a movie
that had a tough go of it I know it was
the Tom Cruise thing or the title that
people didn't like but this thing
deserve be seen way more than it
actually was I think maybe the title was
something was part of it edge of
tomorrow it's a bit of a generic title
to the point that actually lived I
repeat is featured more prominently
that's the tagline not even the title
but anyways it's not only a stellar
concept we every time the guy dies he
starts the day over again that's a solid
concept to start with but just the way
that concept gets executed is phenomenal
because it allows a real true arc and
transformation for Tom Cruise's
character and Tom Cruise gives up
magnificent this actually his
performance in this film is almost an
encapsulation of everything he does well
because he can do smarmy cocky dick head
almost better than anybody in the
business and he's still completely
viable as an action badass so to see him
go from one to the other and in a
completely believable and earn dark
that's magic right there and Emily Blunt
absolutely stellar there's just a great
vibe to this movie and frankly at times
it is hilarious especially in the early
parts number six guardians of the galaxy
you couldn't have guessed with a little
bit of what I said about the lego movie
I am kind of a sucker for movies that
have no right to exist much less work
and you know what guardians the galaxy
definitely fits that model a bunch of
characters nobody's heard of nobody
cares about and should be way too weird
to ever succeed in a mainstream film
being given a massive budget to actually
realize this stuff correctly this is a
thing of beauty because honestly this is
the kind of movie that did get made a
lot back kind of in the 80s but never
had the budget to do it right there were
tons of sort of would-be star wars with
lots of really weird ideas and weird
aliens they were they were dime a dozen
but they were all crap because they had
no money this one hey Marvel put the
money on the support behind James Gunn
and his vision of these characters and
of this story it's just a blast this was
just fun incredibly fun there's there's
no better word for this movie the
characters are fun the action is fun the
movie is just condensed fun number five
big hero 6 one of the few that I
actually did do a proper review on and
this one is technically a Marvel
property but this one hands down props
go to Disney because they throw away so
much of the original product then really
it was just a couple of names and the
fact that it is technically a superhero
movie other than that this is pure
Disney all the way just the bonding
between hero and baymax baymax he
actually supplanted grouped as my
favorite adorable sidekick of this year
and group was awesome but baymax he's to
ease baymax stellar action a lot of fun
very funny it has but also very touching
a lot of heart in this movie and a
celebration of intellect and of
intelligence which does not get
celebrated all that much in movies it's
kind of getting a lot of celebration TV
where you find a lot of those really
crazy intelligent characters with things
like all the various incarnations of
NCIS or CSI Sherlock elementary house
when that was on but we don't get this
sort of celebration of intellect in film
nearly as much so it to see it in a kid
film and well executed in kids film
death that's just nice before
snowpiercer again one of the few that I
did do a proper review on because this
thing had a limited release and it
deserves to be seen so much more than it
has so if you have a chance to check it
out please check it out sci-fi with a
message that still has a ton of action
and just impactful stuff i'll repeat now
what i said in my proper review which is
that you have to get out of the standard
American blockbuster mentality because
of the way the film is paced action is
front-loaded the point at which things
would normally just barrel nonstop to
the end is where the film slows down and
forces you to actually put a lot of
thought into what it is that you have
been shown up to this point but if you
can get in that headspace there has been
nothing else like this for years and it
contains some absolutely phenomenal
performances from chris evans and Tilda
Swinton especially you will not be
forgetting her anytime soon number three
captain america the winter soldier
speaking of chris evans you know as
someone who was not a huge fan of the
first captain america movie and he was
there and fine and avengers who would
have called that he was going to be so
awesome in this movie and not just in
the way who's played by the way he is
utilizing the way he has made a symbol
of what America at one point really
wanted to be and what maybe we probably
should still be trying to be but we
clearly aren't anymore and that is the
heart of his clash was shield in the way
they do things I mean I mentioned
guardians of the galaxy that was just
brave and bold and fun this has a lot on
its mind and he goes to the point that
superheroes can do anything they don't
have to just be big cartoonish action
they can be and they can do that very
well but they can be used to tell more
subversive stories and to deal with
bigger issues they don't have to shy
away from this stuff if you put the
right hero character with the right type
of message and the right type of
exploration of issues the correct
marriage will work perfectly and this
was absolutely the correct marriage of
character material message wonderful
stuff number two
dawn of the Planet of the Apes I thought
this was going to be a good movie I had
no idea was gonna be this good why the
Planet of the Apes was a film that I
thought was gonna be okay and just blew
me away so I actually have raised
expectations already the fact that it
blew my raised expectations out of the
water I did the performance is not only
from andy serkis is Caesar but from all
of the ape actors and also from the
humans both sides done perfectly action
is intense the messages are great the
story does not go the obvious route as
the film continued on I truly did not
know where was gonna go and how was
gonna end do you know how rare that is
for somebody who goes to a lot of movies
and takes in a lot of entertainment to
not know what's gonna happen that is
such a rare thing and such a precious
thing and not even have it be a case of
well it'll need to be that or that these
are the only two options which way will
they go I just had no clue as the film
progresses I was like oh ok I see what
whoa okay but that oh wait hold on and
I'm just being taken along for this
amazing journey in this amazing ride and
not knowing where it's taking me and
where it does take me is just fantastic
so what's number one well if you pay
attention to the fact that one of my
series is called the animation junkie
maybe you could have guessed this one
how to train your dragon 2 this was
undoubtedly my favorite time at the
movies this year I remember the first
out of train your dragon was one of the
few films along with avatar that I would
say go and see it in 3d it's it's worth
the extra money because the flying and
3d was amazing but it's not just the
flying the story and in the story the
first one was great in this sort of
bonding between hiccup and toothless and
what was going on with hiccup and his
dad but now the way the whole story has
progressed and evolved and we're seeing
hiccups journey as he he becomes a man I
mean how rare is it for an animated film
ostensibly in the kids to basically be
truly about growing up not about sort of
not being kidding but becoming an adult
I mean that it doesn't
happen often where do we my lion king
did that very few animated films ever
tackle this and this film tackles it
amazingly and again like Donna Planet of
the Apes it takes a number of terms that
I absolutely would not have called there
are certain things that happen in the
plot but I think oh I know it's got to
happen next but what happened next was
not what I expected it didn't have me
quite as I have no idea what's kind of
happened next as dawn of the Planet of
the Apes did but the fact that it was
able to do it to the degree that it did
is just more icing on this cake glorious
and its triumphant and it's beautiful
and the action is great and the heart is
there right from the beginning I loved
it start to finish and absolutely my
number one pick for 2014 now like I said
they're God there were gonna be a lot of
things missing from here because still a
lot of films I haven't seen you so
rather than throwing at me all the stuff
where was this where was this well
answer is probably gonna be I haven't
seen it yet so rather than hammering me
with all the ones i miss why don't you
tell me what is your personal top ten
drop it down in the comments and let's
talk about it and until next time this
council is a jerk